- Hello, everyone.
I'm Saad Omer, I'm the director
of Yale Institute for Global Health.
In addition to YIGH, we are
indebted to the MacMillan Center
at Yale for co-sponsoring today's event.
It's an honor for me to
introduce today's guest,
U.S. Senator Chris Murphy.
Senator Murphy has been a
strong voice in the Senate
fighting for job creation,
affordable healthcare,
education, sensible gun laws,
and a forward-looking foreign policy,
including the, and of particular
interest to us, global health.
As a member of the Foreign
Relations Committee,
the Health, Education, Labor
and Pensions committee,
appropriately sort of abbreviated often
as the HELP committee and
the appropriations committee,
Senator Murphy has played a key role
and continues to play a
key role in policymaking
around critical global health issues.
For example, he has introduced
the Global Health Security
and Diplomacy Act, GHSDA,
a legislation that is geared
towards better detection,
deterrence, and containment of
infectious disease outbreaks
overseas before they
become global pandemics.
As we will learn more today,
he was an early champion
for a very robust response
to the COVID-19 pandemic.
And he has also advocated
for a range of issues
in global health, including primary care,
tuberculosis, and many other issues.
We intentionally,
we initially had the intention
to have an hour-long program.
However, given the
deliberations that are happening
in Congress around budget
reconciliation and other issues,
i.e. Senator Murphy's day job,
our conversation today
will be around 30 minutes.
While we won't be able to take
audience's questions today
because of that change in time,
I'm looking forward to a great
discussion, nevertheless.
Welcome, Senator Murphy.
We are so pleased to
have you with us today.
- Dr. Omer, thank you very much.
Appreciate you accommodating
my schedule here.
It is a very busy week in the Senate,
but this is still part of my day job,
working not only on continuing to improve
the United States' response to COVID,
putting ourselves back in a
leadership position globally
to help other nations respond,
but also to communicate
what we're working on
to people in Connecticut
and around the country.
So grateful for this opportunity
and looking forward to the conversation.
- My pleasure.
So to get us started,
can you give us a sort
of a big picture view
of how the U.S. Congress
responded to the pandemic
and how it has evolved,
this response has evolved
since the early days of 2020?
- That's a important question
with a probably hour-long answer.
And so I'll give you the
very abbreviated version.
As you mentioned, I was
one of the earliest critics
of the Trump administration's
laissez-faire policy
towards coronavirus early on.
As we all remember,
they were making claims
that it would be dispensed
within a week or two,
and put essentially all of
their eggs in one basket.
That was the travel restriction basket,
instead of requesting early
emergency funding from Congress
in order to start building
a robust supply chain
and training local hospital
and public health staff
around how to deal with early infections
and the early need to track and trace.
They put in place what
ended up being affectless
set of travel restrictions
that ultimately was easily
pierced by the virus.
Congress and Washington
has a deserved reputation
for being defined by
gridlock and stalemate.
I will say 2020, an election year,
was a time of pretty incredible
bipartisan compromise.
On six different occasions,
five, six, seven and a half
a dozen separate occasions,
Congress came together,
Republicans and Democrats,
to pass significant bipartisan legislation
to address the coronavirus crisis.
President Trump didn't lead.
Republicans and Democrats in Congress led.
And so the reason today that
you have small businesses
that are still standing,
the reason why schools
were able to reopen,
that's because Congress passed legislation
from the CARES Act through
to the December legislation
with both parties on board
to respond to the crisis.
Not coincidental to the
election of Joe Biden,
politics started to
creep into the question
of how the political class
talked about coronavirus.
We were largely together through 2020.
But all of a sudden,
when the Democrat came
into the White House,
Republicans started to raise new issues
about vaccine policy and mask wearing.
And now, unfortunately,
many parts of the country
are divided along political lines
as to whether we should
follow a doctor's advice.
And that is a failing
of our political system.
In Connecticut, I think
we've been lucky that, well,
you still find politics.
There's still a crowd that doesn't want
our kids wearing masks in school.
Large Republicans I think in Connecticut
have been at the table,
responsive, thoughtful.
And I think that's part of
the reason why Connecticut
leads the pack nationally when
it comes to vaccination rates
and remains at the bottom of the pack
when it comes to infection rates.
So Congress, I would argue,
had a pretty good 2020,
has not had a very good 2021
in terms of bipartisan
cooperation on COVID.
And as we'll talk about, my
hope is that we recognize
that we have to walk and
chew gum at the same time.
We've gotta protect ourselves
against the current strains of COVID
while standing up a global infrastructure
to identify new strains
and future pathogens.
And that's a lot of the
work that I'm engaged in
on the Foreign Relations committee.
And frankly, Dr. Omer,
we've been very grateful to
have your advice and counsel
on many of the pieces of legislation
that we've been working on here.
I'm grateful for our personal partnership.
- My pleasure, and thanks
for highlighting that
in democracies, these
levels of initiatives
and response to crises
are inevitably political,
but they don't have to be partisan.
And I think we are all served with,
by sort of broad
engagement on some of these
major policy policy issues.
And you have also been
a champion of efforts
to reduce the impact of misinformation
and disinformation during the pandemic,
but broadly around health as well.
What do you think we can
specifically do in this area
of reducing the impact of
misinformation and disinformation?
- As we all know, the
difficulty of getting
square information exists
beyond the health realm.
I was, two weeks ago,
engaging in my annual walk
across the state.
I take about a week every year,
and I walk from one end
of the state to the other.
And I was walking through Middletown,
stopped to see an older
gentleman who was sitting
on a bench, I think waiting for a bus.
And we got in a really
fascinating conversation.
He was a Trump voter in 2016.
He was a Biden voter in 2020.
He's not particularly
partisan or political,
but his biggest worry
was where he should get good information.
He doesn't trust any
information sources these days.
He misses the time when there were only
three news broadcasts,
when he thought that news
was a public contribution of the networks
rather than a source of profit.
And so this is a question
that a lot of Americans are having.
Of course, when it comes
to health misinformation,
it's deadly, right?
You get the wrong
information about politics.
Maybe that causes you to
cast ill-informed vote.
You get the wrong information
about your health,
you may not survive.
There's a Pew Center study suggesting that
about half of the American public reports
having consumed some
amount of misinformation,
fraudulent health information online,
and all of us who've run
into an aunt or an uncle
or a friend who tells us that
you're more likely to die
if you get the vaccine,
we know how easy it is to
pick up that information.
So I really think it's
time for a big investment
in health literacy.
And I don't think this is a particularly
complicated endeavor because, you know,
there are a handful of
very trusted sources,
both public sector and
private sector sources.
And engaging in a public relations effort
to just generally try to explain to people
which sources they can trust
and which sources they can't,
I think that that would
be really constructive.
So I'm building legislation right now
that I've consulted with you, Dr. Omer on.
I'm trying to win some
bipartisan support for it
that would push this
public information campaign
around where to get your
health information from.
And we also, of course,
we're in a constant dialogue
with these social media outlets.
Won't surprise you that
Senator Blumenthal and I
are not satisfied with the degree
to which the big platforms
like Google or Facebook
have policed misinformation.
I mean, I'm watching
Facebook ads on TV right now
in which they're basically defending
their right to put lies on the internet.
And I think that's just
devastating for democracy,
but also devastating for
our COVID relief efforts.
- So switching a little
bit to sort of last year
and combining a couple
of questions together
in the sense that last year,
as part of our response,
the U.S. response, there
were a lot of efforts
to push for a utilization of
the Defense Production Act
and some of the other
interventions to improve,
not only just domestic PPE supply,
personal protective equipment supply,
as well as make sure that
our allies around the world
had PPE and therapeutics to
reduce the spread of COVID-19.
What did those efforts look like,
and how should we think differently
about our supply chains going forward?
And if you wanna elaborate
how you and other members
are approaching through broader
response to the pandemic,
perhaps you might wanna
combine that as well.
But I'm interested in the context
of the Defense Production Act
and some of the sequelae
of some of those events.
- Well, first of all,
utilization of the Defense Production Act
for pandemic response is very much like
trying to take a square peg
and fit it in a round hole.
So, well, I have been amongst
the most vocal proponents
of utilizing the DPA.
We just have to remember,
the DPA is a sort of war time initiative
to give the president of United States
the ability to commandeer
industrial resources
in order to make airplanes, right?
Or whatever you need in order
to fight a foreign enemy.
It was not designed to
produce masks or syringes.
And so now that we are
getting to the point
where we can have some
20/20 vision on 2020,
we should be thinking about rewriting
a version of the DPA,
specifically tailored for health crises.
One of the things we found in 2020
was that the utilization
of the DPA was a mess,
largely because Donald Trump was a mess.
He put it in the hands of his son-in-law,
who had no experience
running big supply chains,
but also because it inherently asks
the Department of Defense
to take a primary role.
The Department of
Defense has no experience
in building these kinds of supply chains.
And as we learned, the
agencies that should
have that kind of
expertise, CDC, NIH and HHS
also weren't very good at it.
So we've gotta sort of
build a permanent capacity
inside the federal government
to manage medical supply chains.
And yes, we need to work with our allies
in order to build the permanent ability
to produce the most important equipment,
the most important supplies necessary.
I think we've just gotta make a decision
that when it comes to certain items,
we can't be reliant on
a Chinese supply chain.
That doesn't mean that
we have to be constantly
making gauze or syringes.
It means that we have to
have the plus up capacity,
the surge capacity in the United States
and our ally structure in
order to meet that demand
should another pandemic occur.
- Wonderful.
So I think there will be hopefully
a lot of sort of policy
changes, some introspection,
and hopefully some legislation
and policy interventions.
Not all of them will be
legislative solutions.
How do we ensure that any policy changes
that are made to strengthen
our pandemic preparedness
are maintained beyond the
current administration
and the tools that are
developed through legislation
are actually utilized?
- Well, it's always a risk in a democracy
that a policy adopted by one government
will be reversed by the next.
But I think if you look
at the areas of alignment
and the areas of distinction
between the parties,
it gives you a little window forward
into where we can create
policy consistency
and where we can't.
Right now, you see the
division that exists
on mask and vaccine mandates.
I don't know that that's
gonna be solved anytime soon,
but there is alignment when it comes
to some of these questions
were just discussing,
like supply chain.
I think there's a growing agreement
inside the Republican party
that we need to have an
industrial policy as a nation.
And that belief sort of comes out
of the experience of COVID,
but it also comes out
of the crisis we've seen
with semiconductors and
other critical items
for the industrial supply chain.
So the Senate, back in the
summer, maybe late spring,
early summer, passed a bipartisan bill
that for the first time ever
really advanced a U.S. industrial policy.
We actually allocated billions of dollars
to help subsidize
industry in critical areas
so that we can compete with China.
So I think if we do reevaluate
some of these issues
around supply chain and readiness,
we can guarantee some consistency
from administration to administration.
- Wonderful.
So you were one of the early supporters
of U.S. engagement and
funding for the Coalition
for Epidemic Preparedness Innovations
and other similar measures.
And for our sort of audiences,
not everyone would be familiar with it.
It was this entity created
right around the Ebola outbreak,
2014, 2015 outbreak to
speed up the availability
of vaccines around the world,
especially in low-income countries
and have those vaccines
ready for phase three trials
after doing initial development.
For a while, until very recently,
until the Biden administration,
there were funders of
that entity that raised
from Ethiopia to Norway
and Britain in between,
but the U.S. was
conspicuous by its absence.
I know that you have
been an early supporter
of that initiative and similar measures.
Any thoughts on going forward?
How do we look at initiatives like CEPI?
Or is there anything else that comes out
of this process that fills that gap?
- I think this is a fascinating
and really important debate,
how to properly set up
incentive structures
to get safe and effective vaccines
for emerging pathogens
as quickly as possible.
I, as you mentioned, have
come to the conclusion
that we need to be invested
in international cooperation.
And CEPI is, in my mind,
a place to do that.
The Biden administration has
invested, but not enough.
The Trump administration
sort of sat on the sidelines,
let others invest in CEPI.
The Biden administration has jumped in,
but not with two feet.
I think we can do better.
I don't think that that
eliminates our domestic ability
to pursue our own vaccine pathways.
There's some that say,
well, we shouldn't be
in the business of
international cooperation
because coronavirus was actually a example
of how nation v. nation competition
expedited the development of vaccines.
That everybody knew they
had to do it on their own.
There was no guarantee
you were gonna be saved by somebody else.
So there was a massive investment,
and you ended up with
European work, U.S. work,
Chinese, Russian work.
I don't think it's an either/or question.
I think it's a both/and.
I think you can both develop
your own domestic capability
to create a vaccine and be robustly
cooperating in space like CEPI.
I'm worried about some
of my colleagues' ability
to view this as a two
mutually exclusive options.
So I continue to press the administration
to both plus up our domestic investment
in vaccine research and make
a big contribution to CEPI.
I don't think we're
gonna lose if we do both.
- Yeah.
So you have an interest in place
in our sort of in our
legislative and policy process.
So in addition to serving
on the Health, Education,
Labor and Pensions or the
so-called HELP Committee,
you also serve on the
Foreign Relations Committee.
From a global health perspective
and from a foreign policy perspective,
there's a lot of, I would say, instability
in the U.S. interaction with China.
Things are evolving, things are changing.
We are certainly not
in the early-2000s era
in terms of interaction with China.
So specifically, sort of keeping
sort of those perspectives in mind,
health and foreign relations,
how do you see the balance of competition
versus collaboration
with China going forward?
- Well, I think the fight
of the next 50 years
will be between U.S. style democracy
and Chinese style autocracy.
The Chinese believe
that American democracy
and European democracy
is withering on the vine.
They think that COVID is
an example of how democracy
and democratic institutions
have become so sclerotic
that they aren't able to adapt
in order to meet new threats.
And well, coronavirus began in China.
They would argue that their system
was much more effective
at stamping it out.
Obviously, at great
cost to civil liberties.
And so we've got a lot
of work to do at home
in order to improve the
state of U.S. democracy.
We have to show that
our democracy can rise
to meet the challenges of today,
which is why the Build Back Better Agenda
that we're discussing right now,
asking the very wealthy
to pay their fair share
to fund investments in
the middle of America,
I think that's important
to our global competition
with China, as our efforts to make sure
that everybody in this
country has the right to vote.
But maybe on the top five list
of devastating Trump era policies
was the decision to withdraw from the WHO.
I mean, I don't know that we will recover
from that decision during the first term
of the Biden administration,
because China, having become
the biggest player there
in our absence, isn't going to give up
that position of hegemony easily.
They are right now the biggest contributor
to many UN agencies.
The UN feels that China
is a more reliable donor
often than the United States is.
So as we try to compete with China,
as we try to make sure that
U.S. health regulations,
U.S. and European health standards
become the rules of the road,
we've gotta be present in a big way
in these multilateral bodies.
And so this is a time,
and I'm arguing this
at the Foreign Relations
Committee for the United States
to double down on our participation
in these organizations.
That's one way that we step up
to the plate on China competition.
- As you know that we have
had cyclical interest,
a boom and bust cycle
of public health funding
in this country, public
health departments,
we were very fortunate in Connecticut
for our state leadership in
terms of getting the job done
with the pandemic, especially
the immunization program
and so and so forth.
But generally speaking, the capabilities
of the health departments
have been eroded substantially
because of these,
partially because of these
boom and bust cycles.
Are there any, maybe it's too
early to ask that question,
but has there been any
thinking to get out of that?
To use policy leavers
that add predictability
to some of those resources
that health departments specifically,
but also federal agencies
like the CDC, et cetera, can expect?
- I was just having this
discussion this morning
in my office with Kathy Silard,
who's the CEO of the Stamford
Hospital Health System.
She was talking about a
really impactful model
that they created and
disseminated around Stamford
to try to get vaccines into low-income
and non-English speaking communities.
They have extraordinary success rate.
And to her mind,
and it was a really
important collaboration
between the hospital
public health, the city,
local health nonprofits,
and they were successful in
those low-income neighborhoods
in getting 81% vaccine penetration,
which is really remarkable.
Better than we've seen in
many other like neighborhoods
throughout the state and country.
But that's because we
funded that effort, right?
That's because we decided
to spend billions of dollars
in relatively flexible funding
so that Stamford Hospital could design,
Yale New Haven could design
public health programs
that empower public health professionals
to spend the time that
was necessary with people
to get them into the necessary program.
In this case, the program was
simple: a shot in your arm.
In other cases, the programs
are more complicated,
whether it be recovery programs
or mental health treatment programs.
But the tools are the same.
Public health workers out
there in the community,
working outside of a fee
for service structure
in a coordinated way.
So your question is whether
we've learned lessons here.
I think the answer is we haven't.
I mean, right now, there's
not the kind of talk
there should be in replicating
some of the models we use
for vaccine distribution, for addiction,
for mental health, for obesity.
And that's really a missed opportunity.
So I'll continue to make that case.
But I will say, a lot of this has to come
from the grass roots up.
Right now, there's so
little accountability
when it comes to public health.
Everybody's doing it.
And we just, from the top-down,
we've designed that system.
But we need some help from
practitioners on the ground
to say, how would we redesign this system?
Right now, public health
districts are doing it.
City governments are doing it.
Hospitals are doing it.
Community health centers are doing it.
Sometimes, they're doing it together.
In some cities, they're
not coordinating at all.
And so when you have such
siloed public health work,
it does make it difficult for the funders,
the federal government,
to decide to come in
and throw more money at it.
So giving us a view as to how we can build
integrated systems might
make the federal funders
more interested in putting
significant money in.
- So just to wrap things
up, moving forward,
what will you and the
Congress be focusing on
to prepare for the next pandemic?
Something perhaps you
haven't mentioned yet,
or something that you wanna
emphasize as we wrap up?
- Well, I'd hit the highlights
of our conversation, right?
We've gotta combat health misinformation.
We've gotta rebuild our supply chains.
We've gotta continue to try
to do work to de-politicize
the conversation around
healthcare and science.
But to finish, we've gotta understand
that if we're not fighting
pathogens everywhere,
we're vulnerable here.
So we've gotta make a big commitment
to global public health.
In this Congress, I
wrote, as you mentioned,
the first sort of
bipartisan bill rebuilding
our global public health infrastructure,
Jim Risch as a hyper conservative Senator.
At the time, the chairman
of the Foreign Relations
Committee from Idaho.
He and I wrote this legislation together.
A version of it was passed
by the Foreign Relations
Committee earlier this year.
And we are just badly
misresourced right now.
We spend 12 to $20 billion a
year in global public health.
We spend $700 billion a year
on conventional military construction.
That is not the right ratio,
given the ratio of threats
that are presented to the United States.
So we've gotta rebuild our public,
our international public health platform.
We've gotta spend more money
on it, because if we don't,
we can build up all the
prophylactics back here at home.
As we saw in 2020, there's
no barrier, there's no wall,
there's no travel
restriction that can stop
a deadly and contagious
virus from hitting us hard.
- So thank you for a
wonderful conversation.
And I must say that I
think we are fortunate
that we have a Senator who
has his ear to the ground
by things like sort of
walk across Connecticut,
and we feel fortunate.
I think you might also feel fortunate
that you represent
Connecticut, not California,
because that would have
been a much longer walk.
- Yeah, and I cheated this year.
I normally go east to west,
which is about 110 miles,
but this year, given in part,
the schedule in Washington,
I went north to south.
So yeah, I have it a lot easier
than most of my colleagues.
- All right.
No, thank you, and thank you to those
who connected to this call.
I wanna remind those
who are sort of present,
our audiences that our
next conversation event
will be with the Dr. Angeli Achrekar,
the acting U.S. Global Aids Coordinator
and Special Representative
for global health diplomacy.
We look forward to seeing you again soon.
And thanks again, Senator.